[Música]
Estados Unidos informa que el ejército
de Sudán y los paramilitares pactaron un
nuevo alto el fuego después del fracaso
de las treguas precedentes miles de
civiles están atrapados y sin
suministros mientras las potencias
extranjeras evacuan a sus nacionales
se cumple un año desde que Manuel macron
fue reelegido después de forzar la
aprobación de la Reforma pensional el
presidente francés entra en el segundo
año de su segundo mandato en el momento
más bajo de su popularidad desde las
protestas de los chalecos amarillos
en Perú lectura de cargos en la
audiencia de Alejandro Toledo la
justicia peruana Investiga el
expresidente extraditado ayer desde
Estados Unidos de recibir sobornos
millonarios a cambio de licitar obra
pública a la empresa odebrecht
conectamos con lima
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
maceu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
abrimos esta edición informativa con
información relativa a Sudán porque el
secretario de estado de Estados Unidos
Anthony blinken informó que el ejército
sudanés y los paramilitares acordaron
Establecer un alto el fuego a partir de
Esta media noche además las fuerzas de
apoyo rápido confirmaron que La tregua
es de 72 horas sin embargo las cuatro
treguas anteriores pactadas a lo largo
de estos 10 días de combates han
fracasado y los civiles se encuentran
atrapados en medio de los
enfrentamientos en que han muerto más de
400 personas Ramiro cuevarberena nos
cuenta más
por tierra por aire y por mar la
comunidad internacional intensificó las
evacuaciones de los ciudadanos y
personal diplomático que permanecía en
Sudán en complejas operaciones los
países intervinieron para sacar a sus
ciudadanos del territorio azotado por un
conflicto interno entre las facciones
militares el jefe diplomático de la
Unión Europea el Joshua destacó el
trabajo de los países del bloque
operation
ha sido una operación compleja y exitosa
en primer lugar 21 funcionarios del
personal de la Unión Europea ya están en
Europa y muchos más ciudadanos de la
Unión Europea y otros ya están fuera de
Sudán son más de mil personas que ya
están seguras
autosudán
Quiero agradecer especialmente a Francia
por evacuar a nuestra gente y Quiero
agradecer los esfuerzos conjuntos de
muchos países que sacaron a sus
nacionales pero también a todos los
nacionales que pudieron elegir
las evacuaciones que incluyen la
ciudadana sudaneses que huyen hacia
países vecinos como Egipto se
completaron casi sin incidentes un
convoy francés fue atacado por un
tirador del ejército regular mientras
era escotado por paramilitares y dejó en
civil herido algunos evacuados han
llegado a sus países de origen pero la
mayoría fue trasladada a shibuty un
pequeño territorio de la región que
alberga instalaciones militares
extranjeras
[Música]
gracias a Dios estoy a salvo eso es lo
principal mi familia está a salvo me
gustaría agradecer a las fuerzas
especiales de Francia por la increíble
misión no es fácil evacuar tus propios
ciudadanos y a los ciudadanos de otras
nacionalidades
nunca vio un plan tan eficiente y
brillante no soy militar Pero esto fue
ejecutado a la perfección puede ver que
ninguna vida se perdió todo el mundo
está a salvo
Sudán transito en la violenta situación
entre el ejército y el grupo paramilitar
fuerzas de apoyo rápido reiterados
pactos para detener el fuego han sido
violados en los últimos días y genera
preocupación no solo en países vecinos
que empiezan a sentir las secuelas del
conflicto sino también en la comunidad
internacional
cambiamos de información vamos a Francia
porque la impopularidad del presidente
Manuel macron alcanzó cifras récord
precisamente cuando hoy se cumple un año
desde que fue reelegido frente a Marín
le pen y aunque durante la campaña y
tras su reelección macron concedió que
muchos votantes no apoyaban su proyecto
sino que lo votaron para impedir la
llegada de la extrema derecha al poder
el mandatario usa su Victoria en las
urnas para legitimar proyectos tan
impopulares como la reforma pensional
Gabriel colchen nos amplía
un año después de su reelección Emmanuel
macún busca recuperarse de la crisis
social y política en la cual está
asumido el país su tasa de popularidad
ha bajado en las últimas semanas con
solo el 26% de franceses satisfechos con
su trabajo y un 47% muy insatisfechos se
debe en gran parte a la adopción por
decreto y sin voto de la asamblea
nacional de la muy popular reforma de
las pensiones parte de los franceses
acusa A Emmanuel macú de gobernar de
manera autoritaria y de estar
desconectado de la sociedad
hoy tenemos la impresión de estar ante
un gobierno sordo que no está en
absoluto por la comunicación tenemos la
impresión de que Manuel macron no tiene
absolutamente nada que ver con lo que
ocurre en su propio país
si su gobierno Ha logrado bajar la tasa
de desempleo y ha empezado a
reindustrializar el país estos efectos
no se sienten la inflación sigue arriba
de 5% y el poder adquisitivo se ve muy
afectado a pesar de las ayudas del
gobierno finalmente el jefe de estado no
logra imponerse como intermediario en la
escena internacional sus intentos de
dialogar con los mandatarios justo y
chino para encontrar una solución a la
guerra en Ucrania no han dado frutos
recientemente también fue criticado por
sus declaraciones sobre Taiwán y su
llamado a ser independiente de Estados
Unidos sobre esta cuestión ahora el
mandatario quiere restablecer el diálogo
con los franceses
se está expresando esta cólera no
esperaba otra cosa pero no me impedirá
seguir moviéndome por el país porque
tenemos que seguir actuando y avanzando
100 días para relanzar su mandato que
debería centrarse en la transición
ecológica el jefe de estado buscará
adoptar nuevas reformas pero sin mayoría
en la asamblea nacional y con un fuerte
descontento social los tres años que le
quedan pueden ser desafiantes
y el Ministerio de relaciones exteriores
de China ha declarado en un comunicado
que respeta la integridad territorial de
todos los países se trata de la reacción
de Beijing para intentar calmar las
tensiones desatadas en la Unión Europea
por el comentario de su embajador en
París que cuestionó la soberanía de los
países bálticos en tanto que Estados
exoviéticos
mientras la guerra continúa en Ucrania y
cuando kiev se prepara para una
contrafensiva en primavera los
comentarios del embajador de china en
Francia han provocado la indignación de
toda Europa
en su aparición en el Canal de noticias
francés lci se negó a decirse La crimea
anexionada Era De hecho parte de Ucrania
luego pasó a decir que los países que
surgieron después de la caída de la
unión soviética no tienen estatuto
afectivo en virtud del derecho
internacional porque no hay ningún
acuerdo internacional que confirme su
condición de Naciones soberanas
estos comentarios ponen entre dicho no
sólo Ucrania sino a todas las antiguas
repúblicas soviéticas que surgieron como
naciones independientes tras la caída de
la unión soviética en 1991 El lunes los
líderes de las tres naciones bálticas de
la Unión Europea Estonia letonia y
lituania convocaron a los enviados de
China para que explicaran sus
comentarios
pedir una aclaración si ha cambiado la
posición de China sobre la independencia
y recordarle que no somos países
posopiéticos somos los países que fueron
ocupados ilegalmente por la unión
soviética el máximo responsable de
política exterior de la Unión Europea
josep borrell calificó de inaceptables
las declaraciones del enviado chino y
dijo que el bloque también quería una
explicación el lunes el Ministerio de
asuntos exteriores de Beijing trató de
calmar la polémica retractándose de los
comentarios del embajador la posición de
China sobre las cuestiones relevantes no
ha cambiado china respeta el estatus de
soberanía de los países de la antigua
Unión soviética tras la disolución de la
unión soviética no es la primera que luz
desata la polémica en 2021 se peleó en
las redes sociales con un investigador
francés al que llamó pequeño matón y
troll también ha remitido contra un
grupo de legisladores franceses que se
plantean viajar a Taiwán que china
considera parte de su territorio
y después de cruzarse duros discursos en
el Consejo de Seguridad de la ONU sobre
la invasión rusa Ucrania y el papel de
occidente y Estados Unidos el secretario
general de la ONU Antonio Gutiérrez y el
ministro de exteriores ruso cuyo país
preside este mes el Consejo de Seguridad
se reunieron Gutiérrez entregó alabrof
una carta para el presidente ruso
Vladimir Putin para extender y mejorar
el acuerdo de exportación de cereales
ucranianos por el mar Negro Rusia se ha
mostrado reacia prolongar el pacto si no
se facilitan sus exportaciones de
fertilizantes preocupación de la que
Gutiérrez tomó nota también se enviaron
cartas a los otros dos países afirmantes
del acuerdo hablamos de Ucrania y de
Turquía
y en España este lunes fueron exhumados
los restos de José Antonio Primo de
Rivera fundador del partido fascista la
falange la exhumación se ejecuta en
cumplimiento de la nueva ley de memoria
democrática que impide que cualquier
figura vinculada al golpe militar de
1936 se ha enterrada en un lugar público
ni que se le rindan homenajes desde
Madrid Marina Colorado con los detalles
España Avanza en el cumplimiento de la
ley de memoria democrática que desde
octubre de 2022 condena por primera vez
explícitamente el golpe de estado que
desencadenó en la Guerra Civil Española
entre 1936 y 39 y la posterior dictadura
los restos mortales de una de las
figuras principales del fascismo español
José Antonio Primo de Rivera fundador de
la falange española y fusilado por el
bando republicano en el 36 han sido
trasladados a un cementerio de Madrid
desde la basílica del Valle de los
caídos un mausoleo católico construido
por presos políticos durante la
dictadura de Francisco Franco y que el
gobierno quiere ahora reconvertir en un
lugar de homenaje y reconocimiento de
todas las víctimas de la Guerra Civil
Española la exhumación de primo de
ribera se celebró por voluntad de la
familia y a puertas cerradas Aunque a la
llegada al cementerio en el centro de
Madrid se dieron altercados entre
policía y unos 200 falangistas que
quisieron entrar al recinto tres de
ellos fueron detenidos Este es otro paso
más tras la exhumación en el 2019 del
dictador Franco en terrado en el Valle
de los caídos tras su muerte en 1975 en
el monumento de la hora conocido como
Valle de cuelgamuros a unos 50
kilómetros de la capital española hay
enterradas más de 33.800 personas
pertenecientes a ambos bandos que
murieron durante el conflicto el
siguiente paso del gobierno será exhumar
los restos de 118 personas asesinadas
por los franquistas que han sido
reclamados por sus familiares
y vamos ahora a Perú donde esta tarde se
celebra la audiencia de lectura de
cargos al expresidente Alejandro Toledo
que recordemos fue extraditado ayer
desde Estados Unidos solicitado por las
autoridades peruanas que lo investigan
por el presunto cobro de sobornos
millonarios a cambio de licitar obra
pública a la empresa odebrecht durante
su mandato presidencial conectamos ahora
con nuestro corresponsal en Lima
Francisco Zacarías Francisco Hola de
nuevo qué detalles tenemos
Buenas tardes la audiencia de control de
acusación el expresidente Alejandro
Toledo ha negado presentarse ante el
juez Richard Concepción el abogado de
Toledo Roberto su ha señalado que
Alejandro Toledo no se encuentra en
buenas condiciones tras su ingreso a la
cárcel de barbadío en la audiencia de
hoy la fiscalía tiene previsto presentar
pruebas documentos y testimonios de
Testigos que incriminan directamente a
Alejandro Toledo en el presunto
recibimiento de 35 millones de dólares
de coimas de la empresa brasileña
odebrecht pero la defensa de Toledo ha
manifestado que va a presentar 40
observaciones a la acusación de la
fiscalía por colusión agravada y lavado
de activos hay que señalar que la corte
se está tomando un tiempo para revisar
las pruebas los expedientes y la
documentación de este caso que ya lleva
Algunos años existe relativa demora es
cierto y precisamente por esto el
presidente del Congreso José Williams le
pide a la justicia peruana acelerar el
juzgamiento de Alejandro Toledo y
justamente este tiempo valioso que la
defensa de Toledo quiere usar para
llegar a acuerdos con el Ministerio
Público precisamente algunos medios
señalan que la fiscal general de Perú
Patricia Benavides le habría ofrecido a
Alejandro Toledo brindarle el perdón
total si es que el ex gobernante se
acoge a la colaboración eficaz eficaz
justamente en las últimas horas
conversamos con Fernando Toledo y nos
afirma que el ex mandatario se siente
muy seguro de salir en libertad
Francisco Muchas gracias por este
reporte iremos actualizando toda la
información de Perú pero cambiamos de
tema porque en la capital de Haití una
multitud de personas golpeó y quemó con
gasolina a 13 presuntos pandilleros
hasta matarlos el incidente ocurrió Poco
después de que los hombres fueran
liberados por la policía que los había
detenido en una parada de tráfico para
registrarles el vehículo según testigos
citados por la agencia ap los muertos
eran miembros de un grupo armado
relacionado con el asesinato del
expresidente jovenel Moisés en julio de
2021 desde el magnicidio el territorio
está disputado por pandillas enfrentadas
y la situación ha escapado del control
de las autoridades
en otras noticias el presidente de
Estados Unidos Joe biden declaró a la
prensa que planea presentarse a la
reelección para 2024 y se prevé que el
anuncio oficial sea mañana 25 de abril
de momento en el partido demócrata no
hay aspirantes a competir contra biden
en las primarias mientras que en el
republicano Donald Trump se perfila como
el presidenciable más fuerte biden que
cumplió 80 años en noviembre es la
persona más anciana en haber ocupado el
despacho oval y varios episodios en que
se ha mostrado desorientado en público
han abierto el debate sobre si su
avanzada edad es un impedimento para el
desarrollo de sus funciones
hasta aquí las noticias Muchísimas
gracias por su atención
[Música]